thank you
attention attention the president of the
United States
[Music]
thank you
well I want to thank my Secret Service
agents who walked me out here
and I want to thank you all all you kids
for bringing your parents to work
it's a good day
anybody who's supposed to have school
today
all right
it's a real good day then isn't it
well it's great to see you all oh hey
people I'm backing me too
hi everybody
[Music]
well you know what
one of the things that when I was my
kids were little
that I missed the most
was being able to take them to work but
I have in my office over in the over the
Oval Office I have pictures of them on
the White House lawn on days I'm
bringing your kids to school day after
work today
and uh so I don't know which one of you
guys are going to be president of the
United States
we got any presidents here all right man
that's good
then they gotta just gotta make me a
promise though
when you're president
and they say Joe Biden's out in the
waiting room coming to see you promise
me you won't say Joe who
remember me okay
all right well I'll be darned you guys
have any questions for me again you guys
kids don't have a question yes
what's it like being president well
first of all it's probably the greatest
honor anyone in America can have
bestowed on them number one number two
one of the best parts is and I mean this
sincerely you get to meet so many
different people and number three it
also means that you live in this house
it's not a bad place to live you know
and number four it gets to meet folks
like you and I really mean it thank you
thank you what's your name Angel
um what how many people live in the
house how many people live in the house
well right now the only two people live
in the house every night and of the
family is Mrs Biden and me but we have
we have grandchildren and children so I
have a son who lives in California but
comes once in a while with his family
and I have a daughter who lives up in
Philadelphia she's a she works to help
women who are victims of violence and
she's a social worker and every once in
a while she comes down with her husband
and then the best part of it all I have
six grandchildren and I'm crazy about
them and I speak to them every single
day not a joke matter of fact I just got
finished going through the calls and uh
only one of them answered the phone uh
but at least I got to leave a message
and their my oldest granddaughter is
named after one of my daughters who I
lost in an accident a long time ago and
her name is Naomi and then I have number
two I have a daughter who works in the
environmental movement and her name is
Finnegan and named after my mom and
number three my granddaughter I call her
my All-American Girl she was a great
little athlete and she's about to
graduate from college in about two weeks
and and her name her name is she's where
every the nickname we call her is Macy
and then I have two other granddaughter
who I just spoke to did get to speak to
and her name is Natalie and she is a a
senior in high school about to graduate
and go off to college where her Daddy
went to school and then I have a
grandson who's going to be a senior in
high school
and then now I have a new a new baby boy
he's three and a half years old and his
daddy named him after his brother my
deceased son and he's Beau Biden so and
guess what they're crazy about me
because I pay so much attention to them
anybody else have any questions yes baby
what do you have oh
yeah and
um
where are you where are you um
grandsons or granddaughters we're okay
her name is Amelia she wants to know
where my granddaughters are
one granddaughter lives in in
Pennsylvania
in Philadelphia
one granddaughter lives in New York
one granddaughter lives in Washington
one granddaughter lives in Wilmington
Delaware
and the other grandsons my my grandson
lives in California that I left somebody
out didn't I anyway
Philadelphia Wilmington and
I did say five you're right so let me
see I got one in New York
two in Philadelphia
there's a three no three because I got
one granddaughter who is
I don't know
you're confusing me but they're all
around Wilmington
California
New York and Philadelphia the cities
they live in
yes honey
why do I want to become the president
well you know when I was younger 120
years ago
when I was younger I was in uh I lived
in a state that it was very hard for
African-Americans to have a fair chance
it was segregated by law and so as a
high school student I got involved with
called the Civil Rights Movement and so
one of the things was happening in my
state was we were trying to get people
to run to fight for civil rights and
we're having trouble getting that many
people to run when I started off and
they asked me to run and I said I didn't
want to and then my sister who's my best
friend my sister used to be three years
younger than me now she's 20 years
younger than me
we went to the same University she
graduated with honors I graduated but
she managed my campaign and so we ran in
a district with my team the team I
belonged to hadn't won and uh so I said
okay it runs being a good sport
but guess what we won because of my
sister
and next thing I know they one thing had
one thing came after another and then it
turned out that uh I ended up being a
senator for a long time and then Barack
Obama President Obama asked me to be his
vice president and then I ran for
president four years later
yes honey
now she's talking my language what's my
favorite ice cream flavor
I may be among the dullest presidents of
the world because I'm known for two
things my Ray-Ban sunglasses and
chocolate chip ice cream
that's my favorite down here yes what's
your what's your question honey
next generation of America
you
he said what makes me hopeful for the
next generation of Americans
the generation Americans from you guys
to people all the way to the late 20s
is the most open
the least prejudiced the best educated
and the most giving generation in
American history for real
not a joke and that's why I'm so hopeful
because an Amer in America we can do
anything anything at all if we do it
together for real there's not a single
thing we can't do and what gives me the
most hope is all you guys for real and
that's the God's truth anyway yes what's
your favorite color my favorite color is
blue
all right not because when I started off
it wasn't red and blue States it was
everything was anyway but that's my
favorite color
how did you become a president I became
a president by going asking people like
your mommy and daddy and I don't know
your mom and daddy but asking them to
look me over I'd say look me over if you
like what you see help out if not vote
for the other guy but give me a look and
but I ran because I think America is not
only the greatest nation in the world
but we have we can do more than any
other Nation to keep peace and help
people going I'm going to take two I'm
getting myself in trouble here because
your parents are saying when's he going
to stop
and My Secret Service agents they're
packing so I got to be careful what they
tell I'm going to go down this end for
just a minute okay and then I'll finish
up here
okay
hang on
the lady in pink
me
fireworks hello Okay
um
um what have you eaten for breakfast and
also can I have a fist bump you're gonna
have a fist bump
and I had a bacon and cheese on a
croissant
I mean bacon scrambled egg and cheese on
a croissant I forgot the scrambled egg
yes honey
sure you can't fist pump
you sure can my name is Sophie um I was
wondering what your biggest
accomplishment so far in the white house
has been well I think the biggest
accomplishment we've had so far is
helping people be able to get health
care
and be able to afford health care you
know people need you know your moms and
dads and a lot of people you know need
prescription drugs they need a
prescription to stay healthy I'll give
you one example do you know anybody any
of you kids know anybody who has
diabetes any kid you know
well guess what it used to be when I
came to office to pay for the diabetes
for a month a lot of parents had to pay
three four five hundred dollars a month
well I was able to change it they don't
have to pay more than they'll not come
to pay more than 35 dollars a month for
that those kinds of things the other
thing is I think one of the biggest
things is and that's gonna it's not
complicated but it is a little bit uh
there is a concern
when I got elected whether or not I'll
I'll get your question
there is a concern that whether or not
we would hold all of our allies together
the people in Europe France England
Italy Germany to stay in one thing
called NATO the North Atlantic Treaty
assembly and we've always been able to
keep the peace since World War II that
way
and so I spent a lot of time pulling all
those folks together to stay on the same
page to take on the Russian aggression
what they're doing to the poor people in
Ukraine and so I think I consider that
an accomplishment and the third thing I
think is an accomplishment is that you
know we have to to be the strongest and
most prosperous nation in the world we
have to have the best what they call
infrastructure Bridges roads highways
internet all those things and I was able
to convince a lot of my Republican
friends to join us and so we passed a
significant bill of rebuild all our
roads and all the things that are going
to make your duration much much stronger
yes honey
um
who is your biggest inspiration
my biggest inspiration
uh let me see who and politically my
biggest inspiration was probably Dr
Martin Luther King but in terms of
personally my biggest inspiration where
my mom and my dad
my mom for real my dad used to say
things when he was alive he'd say
remember
to be a person of your word to be a man
or a woman of your word you have to keep
your word whatever you say you have to
commit to you have to stick with what
you say and tell the truth and it really
does matter and my mom used to say just
remember Joey never bow never been never
kneel just get up and fight back
and that's surreal and so I think my mom
and dad are my two biggest inspirations
yes
[Music]
guards in the building
well other than the four secret service
people over there right in front of the
podium
but you know tell you the truth I don't
know how many there there's a whole
bunch though
there's a there's a whole bunch
I I don't know honey there's a there's a
lot I wish I knew the number I don't
know
yes baby
well what's it like in the White House
well here come here
you hang with me for a minute
and you don't want to go in the White
House okay all right okay
do you watch the Stanley Cup playoffs
and if you do do you have a favorite
team I did and I do the Philadelphia
Flyers
I'm burning for the Devils all right
it's a good thing
can I have a fist bump yes there you go
hey man
well let me grab that
who what was your favorite team
I got to admit it was the other team for
me
but Kansas City pretty cool you ready
there you go
what do I say whatever you want to say
you want to make a speech
did you have a question yes
tell me what it is
Yuri Newman
okay
can't answer that one
the last country I've traveled I'm
drinking once for the last one I was in
I I've been to 89 I met with 89 heads of
state so far so I'm trying to think what
was the last where was the last place I
was it's hard to keep track
um
I was I mean yeah you're right Ireland
that's where it was
how did you know that
oh you're kidding me all right man
okay
yes
what is your favorite Rose in the Rose
Garden
my favorite Rose is the white rose
and the reason that's my favorite Rose
is that that's the rose always give my
wife the white rose folks I'm keeping a
long long time and I promise I'll answer
some questions back here but let me just
say to you know
your mommy and daddies are doing really
important work for real
and you know in America
you're allowed to have
really different points of view you can
really disagree on which direction you
think you should cut that we should take
the country whether we should be
spending money on this program or that
program or we should be dealing with one
country or another
but in the past we've always at the end
of the day come together
we've always come together
and so the most important thing to
remember is that I mean it is you know
America is the most unusual country in
the world
for you little kids unique meaning
there's not any other country like it
most countries
become countries because they are all
the same religion or they're all the
same ethnicity or they all have the same
backgrounds they're all all very similar
but America is the only country
that was built on an idea and no matter
how young you are I hope you remember
the idea and that is that we're based
not on on where we live not the
geography we're based on this idea
and this is true
it says we hold these truth to be
self-evident that all men and women all
men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator endowed by God
with certain inalienable rights meaning
rights to their deaths they have just
because they're born
and those rights are life
to have a good life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness no other country is
based on that idea
no other country in the world that's
what makes us so special
and that's what makes us the Envy of the
world
and I tell you your moms and dads both
in the press as well as in government
they allow us to be able to make it work
we've never completely reached our goal
but we've never walked away from it so
remember in America you should be able
to do anything you can accomplish
anything and there's an awful lot of
people who have become very very very
consequential and done incredible things
for America because we afford them
access to an education we afford them
access to be able to do neat things so
thank you thank you thank you I can see
everybody's going slow it up Biden we
better get this get back to work but
thank you thank you thank you and I wish
I could take more of your questions but
I I'm going to say hi back here
thank you
thank you thank you thank you appreciate
it
hey guys I didn't ask you guys asked me
any questions
[Music]
and money for the employees of the White
House
what am I going to do to make sure we
have health care for the employees of
the white house we're going to make sure
that we tell the American people what
we're doing and why everybody everybody
paid their fair share in taxes the super
wealthy like regular people pay their
fair share we could easily afford this
you know we have a thousand billionaires
in America
they only pay eight percent of their
taxes your moms and dad pay 20 25
percent of their taxes they don't make
anywhere near that so it's got to make
sure everybody pays their fair share we
can do all these things we can do them
well
yes honey
what part about being president and can
I have a handshake my favorite part
about being president is doing what I'm
doing right now
getting to look the American people in
the eye and hear what's on their mind I
really mean it that's my favorite part
of being present
yes honey what's your favorite Room in
the White House and can I have also have
a shirt my favorite Room in the White
House is the room that's off the bedroom
where you I made into a study where I'm
able to go in there and write my
speeches and do a lot of things very
quietly and I also like that little
place called The Oval Office that's a
pretty neat place too
okay
thank you man what's your question honey
when you became president did it take
crowd in you and taking pictures
all right well yeah it did a little bit
but see I had an advantage when I became
president I had for the previous AI for
eight years shown up every single day in
the Oval Office as vice president so I
got used to being with Barack and being
in that circumstance so it wasn't like
all of a sudden I was just in the
National position but it made it a
little bit easier I'll take one more
question here then I'm gonna go across
and ask
where were you born
that's a good question I was born in a
place called Scranton Pennsylvania and
it's up in north of Philadelphia it's
almost into New York but Scranton
Pennsylvania is where I was born I'll be
right back
on a daily basis what do I do on a daily
basis well without getting into the
whole every morning
I have a meeting with what you call my
the National Security account the people
who are the people collect all the
information overnight the secrets around
the world and fill me in and what they
know is happening and not happening and
so I sit with the still the CIA the head
of the military and I do that every
morning I meet with my chief of staff to
find out what the most important things
are going on that day and then it
depends for example today I'm going to
be anyway it's this the schedule varies
but and then I meet with my press team
and I talk to the press as well yes
what's your favorite movie
favorite movie was the new movie that
was about that guy who flies jet planes
you know who I'm talking about
Top Gun
did you see did you see top one Maverick
that's been my favorite movie I've seen
this year
Mr President I heard you have to get
back to the Oval Office
what was that
oh
Hi how are you hi
what'd you say to you I said you have to
get back to the I heard you had to get
back to the Oval Office
and by the way the one thing I thought
when I got to be president
I get to give orders
but I take more orders than I ever did
and you're right what's your name
Kathleen Kathleen what a beautiful name
Kathleen's reminding me I've got to get
back to the office if I don't go they're
gonna get the Secret Service working on
me so I'm going to be in trouble
well thank you all for taking the time I
appreciate it thank you thank you thank
you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you